we can handle every use case there is
out there I always find myself in
conversations with people who are like
oh we've tried every scheduling to out
there it doesn't do exactly what we want
it to and I'm like try me and they tell
me what it is and I'm like yeah c.com
can do that in reality there is no
reason to actually use anything else if
cow.com is going to do everything Under
One
Roof all right guys bang bang I've got
Bailey here with me Bailey
calendars everyone hates them but
everybody got them what are the major
problems that you guys see with
scheduling and and kind of the calendar
products that been out on the market
that made you guys want to go build
cal.com
yeah I mean we're we're definitely far
from being the first guys on the market
when it comes to calendar scheduling but
the problem is is it's great if you fit
into their Niche small use case but like
let's be real we have people with busy
schedules all sorts of different
workload and scheduling requirements
which usually lead a lot of people to
requiring having some sort of EA that
schedules their stuff and the problem is
is nothing else just goes far enough uh
to to achieve what we want because you
know our our time is complex and we need
a way to be able to manage that
effectively and you know as users of
many different scheduling products on
the market that existed prior to cow.com
none of the others just do enough and we
we realize that and cow.com really is
the direct solution ution to our own
problems um and the problems our
community fa with scheduling um all the
time now when you think of uh the use
cases that fall outside of those normal
uh products that people had been using
previously like what what's an example
of something that uh didn't really fit
into that use case yeah I think a good
example is um you know anybody who's
busy because you know calendar is great
because it just like throws everything
into your calendar but when you actually
want to start um you know putting your
schedule link link out there publicly
and not just um not just letting anybody
book you you know like your time is
important protect it ask people those
upfront questions and then decide
whether you want to have a booking with
them or not or have better control about
like limits to how many meetings you
want to preserve your workload obviously
we wouldn't be doing a good job as as
you know Founders or business people if
you're just taking calls 24 hours a day
um you want to be able to craft a good
work life balance um I think as well a
lot of other scheduling products don't
go anywhere near as far in terms of uh
like privacy and compliance so you know
a lot of people who use cow.com um VCS
PE funds things like that now you're
booking meetings with companies that
you're looking to invest in now imagine
the ramifications if that data got
leaked because you know your calendar is
a direct insight into to everything that
you're doing and there are absolutely no
guarantees with pretty much any other
product out there that they cannot read
or sell your calendar data I mean we
have to have access to read your
calendar data and cow.com because it's
open source because you can literally go
through and audit that code and make
sure that it's not doing anything dodgy
you like cow.com
absolutely flies past anything else in
terms of security and compliance which
means you know we work with people in
you know Finance
um you know banking Healthcare
Healthcare is a huge thing for us um
even government organizations and things
like that um there's there's really just
a a multitude of assurances that you get
with cow.com in terms of longevity
privacy compliance and these things are
huge blockers now obviously cal.com is
uh I would consider the leading open-
Source solution for uh for uh kind of
scheduling platforms what is the
benefits of being open source versus
maybe more of a close Source type
solution yeah so I I think it's it's
always been very it's very much part of
who we are so not just on that privacy
side because everybody could audit the
code but also the fact that everybody
gets an opportunity to to collaborate in
the development of cow.com I think when
people ask you know why is cow.com
better than you know kendle or savy Cal
or any of the others you know I could
sit there all day and tell you every
single feech we had but I think the more
interesting thing to talk about is
because we're open source since day one
we've always been very close with the
community because open source is not
just about one company but a whole
Community coming together to build
something and we have listened to the
unique uh needs of every single person
in the community and either we've built
it because we're listening to their
needs or they're building it and
contributing it via open source and so
we've been able to build so much more of
a comprehensive platform that has you
know talk about Integrations and things
out that everybody needs things to to
communicate with each other and we are
the only scheduling platform out there
that has this completely open app store
um which allows you to build apps on top
of your time build Integrations of the
favorite Services I actually spoke with
a founder of a video conferencing
company a few weeks ago in SF and he
told me that with kendly it was like a
minimum of two years um for them to
build an integration his video
conferencing platform with cal.com he
was able to do that in not even a day's
work that's the power of Open Source now
when you see cal.com current feature set
um it seems like people from across
Industries are all starting to use it
what metrics can you share in terms of
growth adoption uh kind of the number of
meetings like what are the things that
you guys are measuring to see hey this
is
working yeah so with um with 10x our
monthly active users in the past year
um we've doubled total signups since
March this year um we actually ran some
very interesting queries and found out
that for every one user that's using
cow.com because they're going and
sharing their cow.com link people love
the product one user is bringing in 25
new users on average um we've also um
six excute user growth um in the last 12
months obviously this is coming from our
complete sort of bottom up funnel we've
got tons of users that are either new to
scheduling have never used any
scheduling technology before we've got
thousands upon thousands of users every
week that are switching over from cely
and things like that because objectively
we do have a far superior feature set
and you know all the way up to
Enterprises you know the biggest Fortune
500s or governments Healthcare all these
kinds of things they're absolutely
swarming ourselves teams so uh C is very
much something of a unexpected hyp
driven growth so when you start to
actually um understand these users you
see the growth that's happening how are
you funding the company what have you
guys raised what what are those
investors coming from talk a little bit
about kind of actually building the
business
itself yeah I mean so cow.com actually
started from from very sort of humble
beginnings because it was literally just
the project that I worked on for some
fun alongside my full-time job at the
time you know this was about three weeks
of development and then we launched it
on product T and and from the day we
launched on product T you know we got
product of the day product of the week
product of the month all these kinds of
things people were signing up in the
thousands and the tens of thousands um
it all came in a a pretty quick rup and
obviously as soon as you start
disrupting the market like that that's
when VCS reach out so you know from the
time that we launch out very basic
MVP VCS were in our inbox we were you
know negotiating with VCS things like
that um I mean at the time I had like
$600 to my name I was like 17 years old
when I started this you know we we come
literally from nothing in terms of
funding but like very shortly after we
raised a 7.4 million seed round um built
the initial team you know actually had
some good money to go behind this
obviously and my co-founder both quit
our full-time jobs at the time uh and
then jump straight onto this and
obviously that money really sort of
kicked us off the ground and then you
know as we then got closer towards the
time when we actually rebranded to c.com
because it was originally called Keno
you can't get domains this good from the
from the get-go um that's when we raised
our series a which was uh 25 million
series a back and all of this comes from
an absolutely incredible
um cap table of investors and supporters
how did you guys meet as
co-founders interestingly we kind of
bumped into each other on an email chain
um we were both always looking for the
exact same thing because back in the day
if you went out there and searched like
open source alternative to kendly things
like that we actually when we recount
this story both of us we we found
ourselves on the same Reddit threads and
things like that you know just scouring
Google
for the very solution to our problems
and um here my co-founder he had like an
initial idea um but his company at the
time got acquired by onc and he went
into a big head of product role there
and so he wouldn't have had time to work
on it so he reached out to other people
who were interested in their early
supporters things like that I was like
one of the first five people that like
you know ever sort of reached out
regarding the idea and then we sort of
struck up an agreement to actually
co-found this company um and obviously
with the with the growth that it saw we
then quickly you know quit our
respective full-time jobs and just
really went into this
head-on now when you see um two
co-founders that get along kind of
bumped into each other in the way you're
describing raised a lot of money have
these metrics where are you going right
it's kind of you got all the ingredients
but you still gota still got to produce
the plate right you still got to
actually get the meal put together what
is this Vision over the next call it you
know 5 to 10 years that you guys think
uh can take what I think most people
would look at be like hey I need a
calendar that works for me I need a
scheduling platform that works for me
but how big can this get what what does
that look
like well it looks like world domination
in sense so you know the thing is is I
think that you know thank you to cly
they paved the way back in you know sort
of the the 2010s is um and were the
first people out of the door with with
scheduling products made it the new
thing where you can send a link to book
a meeting but the point is is you know I
still have to pick up the phone at 8:00
a.m. just to you know call my doctor and
make an appointment like they're not
aware of scheduling links and things
like that the point is is our our
long-term goal is to get this out to
everyone you know we have a great
product um but we need to put in a ton
of effort into making sure that you know
not just people who typically are aware
of calendar scheduling products you know
Founders or people in Tech obviously
within within that kind of Niche we
perform really well but I personally
want to see that cow.com gets the impact
that nobody in the world has to like
pick up the phone to take appointments
like look at small businesses and things
like that where they are literally you
know they're doing their work and then
they have to get distracted from their
work to then go and pick up the phone
and take appointments it's like why is
that not so by c.com already um so it's
just achieving mass mass adoption from
the bottom up you know these start as
maybe individual users or or small
businesses but then it works all the way
up into I mean we already have like a
few governments that are using cow.com
to power their scheduling it's making
the lives of their citizens you know so
much easier the question is why is not
every government using it or every
public service and things like that I
think that something that me and my
co-founder really care about is we
measure directly like what impacts do we
have on the world how many times do we
see other people using and benefiting
from you know better scheduling
technology now as I think about this
technology open source is really
interesting to me because you're a
company you're being funded uh you then
are soliciting other people to continue
to improve at the product value acrel is
something that a lot of people talk
about in the Bitcoin and crypto World
here is pretty interesting right like on
one hand there's a a business that is
acur value and and continues to grow but
there's also the open source software
and so how do you guys think about like
open source and then like for-profit you
know kind of centralized company and why
is this the best model right like a lot
of people in your situation would just
be like you know what let's just build
close Source technology I understand why
the open source could be valuable to the
user why is it valuable for you all as
as business owners and kind of Founders
building this company
yeah it's a great question because I
mean there's always a very delicate
balance between between those things and
you know in your question you said why
is it the best model it's probably not
even the best model for everybody but
what open source is is something that
has always been you know very C to
cow.com from its Inception and uh you
know will always be so what we see here
is obviously we're here to make impact
on the world and so there's things out
there like refugee camps are using cow
free of charge through open source to
you know schedule schedule services for
their refugees and that's huge to us um
you know there are like the reason why
some of these governments from a bottom
up side can actually even use cow.com is
because fundamentally it's open source
that's not possible with anything else
out there so we're always here we want
to give something back to the world like
we genuinely believe that scheduling is
so core to what everybody does I mean
everybody has a schedule everybody um
you know needs to needs to meet with
others and so we see it as you know we
give something back to the World open
source contributors give something to us
um but we can still charge you know the
businesses and things like that that use
cow.com and turn a profit it's not none
of this with open source it's not a
business strategy it's not
um you know it's not a commercial
reasoning behind it it's more of a we're
just genuinely interested in creating
genuine positive change in the world but
behind a for-profit company
now I always look at the funding
environment and I see okay you guys were
able to raise a ton of money previously
now not so hot right in terms of the
funding environment but the business
still continues to do really well and so
what have you guys seen not just from
the investor side but from the user side
as the Market's gone up the Market's
gone down scheduling doesn't go away so
how are market conditions kind of play
out with the product itself this episode
is brought to you by cal.com what do I
have in common with Chad Hurley from
YouTube Toby from Shopify and Alexis
from 776 and the co-founder of Reddit we
all use cal.com instead of cly and we
are all early investors as well cal.com
is leading the charge of scheduling
Platforms in the open source sphere
offering you the chance to harness the
efficienc previously reserved for leite
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open- source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
user-friendly interface you can
customize it and you can make your
calendar work for you use code pomp for
$500 off when you set up your team with
cow.com today again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time yeah it's always
interesting because I mean you know
although although cow.com has always
been very focused on longevity and
things like that so fundraising has
never been something that's you know too
uh critical for
obviously there is still immense growth
and things like that we've always got
investors in our inboxes and things like
that having calls with us you know if if
you want to raise your next round we'll
be here I think a lot of them are real
Believers in in where we stand to grow
into um and like I say once we really
get sort of that mass adoption and
things like that this is this is
supposed to be a a huge business not
just in terms of um know the dollar
figure but also in terms of the the real
world impact and the amount of users it
has in the world also we see so part of
what cow.com does as well is what we
call like scheduling infrastructure so
long story short nobody wants to
actually build scheduling into your own
product if you're out there building
tella Health if you're out there
building a hiring Marketplace you know
ask ask any head of engineering or
something like that they're going to
tell you it's a terrible idea to build
that yourself so part of what we do is
almost like strip for time you know we
provide a readymade developer kit um and
which handles all the scheduling for you
and you just focus on building a product
so we see a lot of companies that come
up and they're building their entire
company on top of cow.com obviously they
go around they're raising in sort of
like the seed markets or series A's and
things like that and obviously it's a
very attractive thing for them to be
able to put 100% of their time and
effort into their core product and do
what you know makes their
different from everything else rather
than wasting years and millions of
dollars on on scheduling so I think in a
way we've sort of helped Empower some
people to to fund raise as well as you
know having raise two really great
rounds
ourselves what's been the biggest
surprise in building a company so
far how quickly it all takes off you
know and I seriously mean this back in
the day with the um with the MVP and
things like that this was just a project
um not something that we ever said you
know this is going to be A5 billion
business in 20 years or something like
that this was literally creating the
direct solution to our problems because
me and my co-founder were both Builders
at heart you know we we see a problem
and we we build the solution to it and
it it was then on that launch day that
I'm then just like going about my day
and I'm like damn this this really could
be something and then you know over even
subsequent weeks we had um not just the
investors in our in box but the like
even Fortune 500s uh within our in box
within weeks and we we suddenly realized
the impacts that we can have like I say
the stuff to do with government Health
Care refugee camps all these it's all
very very close to our hearts we're
always um you know very very moved by
some of sort of like positive impact
that can that can happen with cow.com
and we're always try and be committed to
to supporting like scheduling for for
good causes and things like that um so
yeah I think it's all just been sort of
a delightful surprise in in how how much
impact and how quickly something can
take
off when you think about um the
scheduling Market in general are there
things that tangentially you can expand
into once you kind of have somebody's
calendar and I think of like the fintech
industry you know if you get deposits
all of a sudden there's plenty of ways
to build other features orone how do you
guys think about that for
scheduling it's it's huge it's it's
absolutely huge so on on a few things
you know when I mentioned we have our
app store earlier the whole idea of that
being able to build apps on top of your
time huge uh and the thing is is cow.com
is the one that's uniquely positioned to
do this because we're open source and
very privacy friendly you know that if
we're going to be the central thing
that's like using your calendar data to
to do all of these useful things you
want to make sure um that we are
obviously respecting your privacy so we
have all sorts of cool apps I mean one
app that we launched recently is CER AI
um which uses AI in the typical sense of
like an assistant where if somebody
emails you hey can we find a time to
meet you can just forward it to your
username at cal. so Bailey cal. and I
say put this on my calendar for next
Wednesday and you know it will use AI
that will then talk with all of the the
core uh cow.com logic because obviously
we've built all of that core logic and
things like that so front-end apps can
just change the way that you interface
with this rather than having to you know
rewrite the book from scratch um and so
we're able to ship like a great AI
experience that people are loving and
you know finding new ways to to schedule
things um we work with a lot of external
companies um they can you know safely
use your calendar data to you know do
all sorts of productivity um productiv
it hacks little apps things like that we
have a we have an app wi my cow you can
just hit one big red button and
reschedule your entire day of meetings
if an emergency comes up like it's it's
amazing to us that we're in such a core
position to to what people do with their
calendars that we can then become sort
of like the central hub for anything
that interacts with your time and we
have a lot of ambitious plans uh into
the future as to how we're going to
expand um all of our at Marketplace do
things like if you want to if you want
to list your availability on a different
site say you join an expert's
Marketplace or something like that
rather than filling in your availability
there that there'll be like a signing
with cow.com buttton and that can then
pull your availability straight from
cow.com things like that um that's a lot
of the real sort of like long-term stuff
that we can that we can build talk a
little bit about some of the trends that
you all see in uh people using the
product right is uh I don't know more
successful people have busier schedules
or less schedules like do you have any
kind of trend analysis uh from some of
the stuff that you guys see with the
with calendar
habits yeah I think we we see an
interesting thing where because because
of all of the advanced options and
things like that that uh cow.com gives
you to to restrict the amount of
bookings you have to like not be doing
more than x amount of meetings a day um
it's we always hear a lot of feedback
from some of the
highest profile people that like don't
want to be blocking up their schedules
with many things I know a lot of people
have different opinions as to how many
meetings you want to have and things
like that but especially for for like
high-profile people they always comment
about like it's great I can now lock
down the amount of uh events that I'm
that I'm having booked into my calendar
I can free up a lot of time I'm not
taking anywhere near as many you know
useless meetings things like that um and
I think especially for positions like
Sals or if you're a Founder things like
that you want to vet who's coming
through to you and with cow.com we have
so many amazing subproducts and features
and apps and things at that that can
just help you take less meetings which
is very ironic considering that we're a
you know a scheduling platform and we
want you to have as little meetings as
possible but it's all just there to to
protect your time and I think that that
definitely one of the things which I
find remarkable in the iony of it that
that we help busy people be less busy I
guess another part of this that seems
pretty interesting to me is um the maker
verse uh kind of manager schedule right
Paul Graham is uh famous for talking
about um in that uh to some degree maybe
you want your managers to have as many
meetings as possible you want your
makers to have as few meetings as
possible uh I see people talking about
artificial intelligence and like they
might be able to write emails for for
you they could do you know all these
like different tasks whatever is there a
world where uh we anticipate like AI
agents meeting with AI agents or like
you know like like how how do you kind
of see artificial intelligence playing
into some of this stuff and uh how much
of it is like hype for actual things
that could be built here quite um I I
could see it being a possibility I mean
the good thing is as well is with
cal.com we move fast um and not just I
mean we've shipped a lot in in a small
period of time with a small team but
also we're we're always sort of on the
Forefront of what's new um you know we
we shipped our AI um like our C AI we'
shipped a number of things to do with
web 3 and crypto whereas like nobody
else is doing that um a lot of other
competitors aren't even shipping regular
features let alone um some of these new
things that I mean like nobody is really
accepting crypto payments or allowing
you to confirm you know membership
within a dow or something like that um
we're doing that you know we're not
we're not playing it too edgy we're
still you know a very Rock Solid and
Stable Company but just through open
source those who are passionate about
some of these new things have the um
ability to build this on top of cow.com
um so I think that we're always testing
the waters and and trying to be at the
Forefront of technology and you know for
now that's about sort of one-sided AI um
in the sense of like making it a lot
more natural to to interact with your
calendar EG almost having like an AI
version of an assistant that can put
things on your calendar and know your
schedule but I think that once the
technology really expands to be able to
do like fully alterate the booking
process between two people and you know
an AI to really understand that uh I I
can always promise you whatever the
technological advancements that are
going on where the with the first people
in the
door now my last question for you is
uh when you all are successful and I say
that as an investor who is uh
financially incentivized to see you be
highly highly successful uh what do you
see as the ramifications to the market
is there like one scheduling platform to
rule them all everyone else dies is
there still kind of a couple of
different options for different people
and how does maybe work change if you
all up being the diamond
platform yeah that's um I mean to be
fair we aim to be the one that rules
them all and I'm not just saying that as
your typical over aspirational founder
you know without basis see the thing is
is we've kind of flipped the script here
it's taking us longer to get started and
things like that because we're trying to
build such a a huge and complex product
but the thing is is in the long run we
we I mean already we can handle every
use case there is out there um no matter
what products you're using we handle
like even some of the more specialized
ones that do certain things in terms of
like um routing sales calls to the right
seniority of sales person dependent on
the size of the deal like we've done
that um I always find myself in
conversations with people who are like
oh we've tried every scheduling tool out
there it doesn't do exactly what we want
it to and I'm like try me
and they tell me what it is and I'm like
yeah cow.com can do that so we've really
put a lot of time and effort into making
something that can really handle like
every use case that you can possibly
throw at us um and I think that in the
long run that will make us become quite
a dominant platform because in reality
there is no reason to actually use
anything else if cow.com is going to do
everything under one roof and that's why
I think the side of us about being open
source and things like that is very
important because you know if we're
going to sort of monopolize the market
you want to make sure that we're doing
that in good faith um you know the as
well this this isn't cow.com isn't
something where we can just like it can
disappear one day and the Monopoly with
buil Falls is because it's open source
it lives on forever um I think there's
there's a certain power in that so yeah
we're always aiming to be the ones to to
just so everybody's use case I think we
already do that um and it's now just a
question of getting everybody across all
those different use cases using cal.com
because once they do they can't stop
telling us and telling Twitter how great
the switch has
been where can we send people to find
you on the internet and find out more
about cal.com
cal.com uh we have like a ton of
resources on our site we have
information for every use case and we
have a great domain that you know you
can just type straight into your url bar
after you hear me say it once so check
out the website whatever um whatever
industry you're in we have we have use
cases suited for you we have featur
suited for you um and if it doesn't do
whatever your whatever it is my email is
Bailey cow.com ask me whatever it is
that cow.com doesn't cover and I
guarantee we will have it or if we don't
have it we will build it awesome Bailey
thank you so much for doing this
definitely do it again in the future
thank you very much